from world famous comedians being
attacked on stage
to audience members getting naked during
the show
these are the craziest comedian vs
Heckler moments starting with number 15
when this fan went after Louis C.K
thank you maybe tell me that later
instead of during a performance
because you're not you're not welcome to
speak I'm trying to make that really
clear
to
everybody at the same time it is not
appropriate to yell [__] at me right now
it is less appropriate to yell at me
than almost anybody
within several square miles
if you yell at a guy on the street
you're not ruining a show for 2500
[__] people so it's literally me
and the pilot you shouldn't talk to
you're the only people heckling Louis CK
is insane but it's still smarter than
picking a fight with Joe Rogan
here you tell me what you just said
why you but why are you yelling out like
that did no one hug you when you're
little
what kind of weird [__] is going on here
I'm trying to sort through this because
you're [__] up the show you
understand that right but once you turn
around look at this 2 000 other people
besides you you know that right
I'm just curious why do you think it's a
good idea to do scale straight up
oh now you're gonna shut up okay he
kicked out [__] you're gonna
talk to me now
power
I'm talking to you why why do you feel
like it's a good idea to just yell [__]
out because you have a limited mind
right
is that what it is is it is what do you
wish that things had gone better and you
got the attention that you feel you
deserve but it didn't work out that way
if you just cry out everywhere you are a
factor of us removing the word from the
vernacular
they think it's okay to do [__] [__]
because there's no real word to describe
people like that anymore that dude's
gonna have some trouble sleeping after
that unlike the guy number 13 who's out
cold listening to Andrew Schultz this
guy
black guy in the second row is
completely passed out
I'm gonna show you how to wake him up
ready
[Applause]
nothing
that's some good [__] weed
how do you wake a black guy up
hold on I got it child support
ready
your father's hitting them
I got it
this naked fat white [__] is everywhere
speaking of fat white [__] there's
one in number 12 who interrupted Bill
Burr
and you're welcome
thank you for not just laughing thank
you for verbally letting you know that
you appreciated that
thank you
Sheila has no stairs in her house or
someone doesn't know how to walk up them
[Applause]
again
she said it not like I was 10 feet away
she sounded like I was downstairs in the
rec room
changing the fuse or something that's
not it
[Applause]
[Music]
I thought she said it that [__] got
roasted for messing with Bill Burr just
like the Lady in Number 11 who went
after the Big Red Machine where the [__]
is she going I'm having the set of my
[__] life right now and some [__] is
getting up to [__] walk off
the [__] is going on
don't come back
[Music]
seriously don't bucking
[__] I'm sick of people getting up
and leaving when I'm on the stage
I'm gonna have a [__] heart attack
speaking of heart attacks Bert Kreischer
almost had one after these people
stormed out of his show in number 10.
are you guys leaving or coming
or sitting are they just tall tops you
guys in trouble
that's how funny you are
tell a joke and you tell me if you like
this one because this is what it's going
to look like after this okay
how does someone become an abortion
doctor
is there really someone in med school
thinking well I want to work with kids
but
[Applause]
Kurt's not the only one who's had
triggered fans walk out cause the number
eight Doug Stanhope makes a joke about
Syria that starts an all-out War she
felt strongly about Syria and they had
to shut her down
I envy oh wow wow
you forgot your jacket now you're gonna
have to make the Walk of Shame for your
jacket
I love I love when people get offended
for absolutely nothing like you just sat
through rape and abortion and child
molesting a fist [__] but Syria
that's where it all falls apart damn get
in the middle finger during a show it's
rough just ask Brian Cowan
or you do not fly I said please
sir hey bro hey Brian do more jokes
about [__] animals
getting heckled by another comedian is
crazy but number seven is even crazier
because nemesh Patel got heckled by a
fire alarm I feel like George Bush when
he learned the towers got hit you know
[Laughter]
George Bush was president when you were
like seven years old
talk about George Bush a bad [__] what
happened
who did that is it an actual fire
do we need to go
I've never been heckled by a fire alarm
before
this is the one thing that's louder than
a microphone speaking of fire things got
hot and heavy in number six when this
audience member started stripping during
the
shows
I don't like that you said I thought you
didn't like that what was the other
topic
[Applause]
what's up
I love you so much
[Applause]
oh my God you're so drunk
that guy was hammered just like this
dude at number five who started showing
Sam Morrell porn during the show
the PornHub he pulled up Pornhub in my
show
you know that'd be a good idea for some
reason
people watch at home
you wanted to break it out in the
showroom
know about it
uh it's a it's a Tuesday
it's most certainly not a Tuesday
it's a Friday
the strangest interruptions to Australia
I'm watching PornHub cool I work pretty
hard on these jokes
also it's not the day you think it is
it's never a good idea to take out your
phone during the show especially when
David Lucas is on stage
are you serious I can't cancel it away
on the side of my neck you never give a
[__] about anything
[Music]
some people just can't take a joke just
like the Lady in Number Three who really
thought she could cancel Mark Norman was
that a boo over there what was that
what's that
we love you mark wait what did I do
supporting prostitution yes I've given
them money for years
[Applause]
[Music]
so crazy you think you're the good guy
in the movie you know
[__] [__] all right um
oh is that her oh great all right wait
what did I do why are you mad I don't
get it
what do you mean I'm promoting it I'm
telling a joke you [__] psycho Jesus
Christ
I don't think she's smart
suck my dick all right well
that's sexual assault you're promoted
ah
where does it end suck my dick I'm sure
that was transphobic in some way if
we're really uh we're really doing the
numbers here ah should have never [__]
her yeah
that Karen was annoying as [__] but the
one in number two might be even worse
sit down super Karen sit down
raise his price and you you shut the
[__] up too I know you're ready to fight
a [__]
[__] German Shepherd both of you
listen to this I don't think there's a
such thing as a bad dog I think there's
bad dog
thank you I got this part you do the
drunk
because everyone was lying
line I'm what's called a professional
that's why they put me on at the end
they're not clapping for you for you
hope you know that's how I know it's not
that everyone has loved you is that
they've tolerated you they look straight
and they go God
oh wow yeah cause that's how it works
and work you go in you clock out you go
to the next job like when you go to work
you show up you give some dude a hand
job and then you leave that's what
happens you show up and then you go do
the next hand job Jesus Christ what are
you mad at are you trying to win a fight
against somebody who's paid to be funny
I will bully you into a suicide note
[__]
she wanted all the smoke and got roasted
which is probably why most crowd members
prefer not to speak at all what are you
guys up to today my friend with the hat
huh waiting for me all day you were just
you you've been here like it's like it's
a Star Wars movie he's just been he was
lined up he was lined up last night with
a sleeping bag
waiting
nice that's a pretty empty life man I'm
sorry to hear that
[Applause]
no what'd you do come on you go you got
a job probably
huh okay just answer directly y'all
I'll handle the quips you just
tell me directly what was going on
what's your nine to five
you said some people have 95.
we can't you're this is easy again yeah
yeah I'm sorry dude what's good first of
all don't talk like we're a divorced
couple
marker we're gonna do it right during
the graduation ceremony we can't wait
till the reception afterwards I'll pay
them I'm a little late I got taken off a
project I don't have the alimony right
now you're gonna embarrass me in front
of her
don't forget who paid for the private
school
laughs
I'm just asking man relax I'm not gonna
[__] it I'm just this is me easing into
the show I don't want to do my jokes you
know what I mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
one man's you know nerve-wracking three
minutes is another man's easing in you
know what I mean
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out